i might unfollow bk again tomorrow just
to keep the media talking about it
we're gonna go full wwe on this thing
florida georgia line is still together
despite recent rumors of a banned
breakup
the speculation about a rift between the
duo began in the midst of the
presidential election
when fans noticed that tyler hubbard and
his wife haley
unfollowed his partner brian kelly on
instagram
but during an appearance on siriusxm's
exit 209 with stormy warren podcast
the pair promised they're still a team
and feeling stronger than ever
island followed bk for a few days while
we were through this political
uh you know in the middle of this
election and everything going on and
and i even called him and told him i
said hey buddy i love you and i love you
a lot more in real life
than on your stories right now so i'm
just gonna so that's why i unfollowed
you nothing personal i still love you
you're still my brother
i just didn't want to see it every time
i opened instagram and so it wasn't a
big deal
like like like we like we said we're
we're on great terms
we're feeling stronger than ever we're
loving and supporting each other through
even all the
chapters that we're in now and uh
excited for the future
now although both brian and tyler
remained fairly apolitical on social
media
tyler has shared posts in favor of joe
biden while brian
seems to be a donald trump supporter and
was among a group of country artists who
called for
live concerts to resume after witnessing
the street celebrations
following biden's victory but just like
any long-term relationship
the duo admit they've gone through their
ups and downs over the last decade
and have even gone to therapy together
it's not all sugar-coated
and so the truth is and i think this is
important to talk about me and bk have
done work
we've witnessed therapy we've sat with
each other and wanted to kill each other
at times but
by the end of it we're hugging it out
you know what i mean because we're
brothers and that's what brothers do
and and brothers don't always get along
so we've had we've had moments where we
you know where we want to kill each
other but a lot of it's out of love and
so we
we uh we put that first and foremost and
we know the importance of our
relationship and how much
um you know how much love we have for
each other so we have worked
over the years we've worked to become
stronger and stronger and stronger and
that's
even through the hard times has made us
stronger as friends and brothers and
partners so
we're really thankful for it now tyler
has been quarantined on his tour bus in
his driveway for nearly two weeks
after testing positive for covet 19 but
these rumors of a split
have definitely kept him entertained
somebody sent me an article two days ago
that me and bk were breaking up and i
thought well
that's news to me uh but thought it was
pretty pretty uh humorous and
entertaining that somebody took
the time to uh notice that in the first
place and then turn it into a story that
fgl's breaking up so
anyways that being said we can't wait to
go on tour next year
together yeah yeah we were literally on
a call yesterday just showing up
the last details of our record and
working on getting some
uh touring uh cities out here soon and
couple
announcements but uh no i just and that
came through in the middle of our team
call and we're just like well that's
interesting
yeah wow we're on a phone call together
right now talking about the future
as for what the future holds it's safe
to say they're in it for the long haul
after
just signing a long-term touring deal
with live nation
and with the covid19 vaccine hopefully
on the way
the duo could be touring as early as
summer 2021